please welcome the incredible Kyra
Knightley and Carrie
okay
thank you thanks for having me oh my God
I am such a massive fan of you guys
and Carrie you've worked with Pedro
Pascal and we talked about him in the
news you guys did a podcast together
when you were with him were you like
obviously everyone's gonna freak out
over him well yeah but he really is is
home it's not a it's not an act he's
really that humble and surprised by
what's happening to him right now he's
so cute I know he's really cute he
really is yeah okay so you are married
in fact Kira you had a 10th wedding
anniversary I have it in May yeah oh
okay
yeah we made it
in a decade to your children and we've
made it a decade
Miracle we might have something in
common which is something about roller
coasters I love roller coasters
yeah no I love roller coasters but you
had a first date well with a roller
coaster I met my husband in a very
drunken way oh I like it so we were very
drunk for our first few days so we don't
really remember them but our first
proper date was I said to him I love
roller coasters so he very sweetly
decided to take me to a theme park just
outside London where they have amazing
roller coasters but he didn't tell me
that he's completely terrified oh like
completely so he was sort of white and
shaking and sweating and we actually
have a picture from our first day on the
massive roller coaster and I'm just like
the happiness is like this is the most
amazing thing and he he literally looks
like he's gonna die like okay
and he's looked like that ever since
well okay now when it comes to weddings
I have to say your wedding story swept
me off my feet oh thank you life and
death because it was so unique yes
please tell us because I love it so much
so in Illinois where we lived in Chicago
you when you register to get married you
have to thank you you have 60 days to
get married but we have to re-register
and repay because you know it's a gift
and so
um I was shooting Gone Girl and it was
Friday night and I said I'm coming home
tomorrow it's the last day of our
registration we have to get married and
so he says yes yes yes so I come home
Friday it's one in the morning he is
sweating profusely in terrible pain we
go to the emergency room Saturday
emergency gallbladder surgery uh he's
recovering Sunday registration over but
I came to the hospital I brought a
sundress and I brought our rings and I
was like is there a chaplain anywhere
and so this woman pops her head and I
was talking to my mom and the sundress
was on a chair and I was wearing Tracy's
red t-shirt and she said hello I'm Pam
I'm a Lutheran and I said I gotta go I'm
getting married and she said I've never
done a wedding before and so she
improvised the wedding ceremony my
husband so over 29 years had Dilaudid
was Hezekiah doesn't remember any of it
and my father said I had to drug him to
get him to marry you you know it was
like that
um okay speaking of Amazing Stories
King Charles so I got I got an Obe which
means officer of the British Empire so
I'm an officer officially oh yeah um
anyway I got a badge from now King
Charles yes no no no no
yeah so I'm wearing this whole outfit
um and I it's a cool outfit you know
it's like but I didn't realize that
inside the palace never been to the
Palace before the walls are exactly that
color
drop but the other
s we have to all line up in a hallway
before you go in to be badged and they
say okay you've got 30 seconds and he
will hold your hand and you you have a
chat and then he will push you off and
then you have to walk backwards and then
you have to do a curtsy but the problem
was he was trying to have a chat to me
and all I was thinking about was how I
was going to walk backwards so I was
backing away
it's actually going no see Stay With Me
go to a quick break and then we'll be
right back with Keira Knightley and
Carrie
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]